[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz klassisches basic
rezept wir werden gemeinsam schupfnudeln
machen
schupfnudeln ich glaube als kind habe
ich die noch nie selbst gemacht gegessen
während ihr einfach immer fertig gekauft
was auch super praktisch ist denn man
muss nicht viel machen aber selbst
gemacht schmecken die wirklich super
lecker dafür braucht ihr wirklich nur
ganz wenige zutaten und wer aus dem
schwäbischen kommt oder aus dem
badischen normalerweise macht man die
schupfnudeln nämlich immer als
resteverwertung das heißt wenn man
kartoffeln vom vortag übrig hat und wir
machen jetzt direkt eine große menge
denn wir sind ein großes team und ich
nehme dafür zwei kilometer kochende
kartoffeln etwas salz eine prise muskat
acht eigelbe sie habe ich noch mehl und
hartweizengrieß auf den ersten blick
scheint so als wenn es wirklich viele
zutaten sind auch weil wirklich eine
große menge machen wenn ihr aber sagt 88
eingriffe sind mir zu viel
dann könnt ihr auch ganze eier nehmen
also statt acht eigene für ganze eier
aber dann wird die farbe eben auch nicht
so schön intensiv aber wahrscheinlich
macht er sowieso erstmal nur die hälfte
des rezept denn davon essen jetzt glaube
ich die nächsten drei tage
und jetzt habe ich hier die kartoffeln
bereits gekocht und kann kurz die schale
appellen
und jetzt drücke ich die kartoffel hier
durch eine kartoffelpresse
[Musik]
hier kamen jetzt noch etwas salz dazu
eine prise muskat natürlich frisch
gerieben
die eigelbe haben die schöne farbe jetzt
das mehl es gebe ich einfach in zwei
drei etappen dazu der gries kommt auch
dazu und jetzt schön kneten können so
auch in der großen küchenmaschine machen
oder mit der hand verkneten
oder wie es ein handrührgerät nutzen
das restliche mehl des
hier auf der backe einfach unter so
erkenne ich auch direkt ob der teig die
perfekte konsistenz hat er sich nicht
mehr kleben also an dem hinten aber
schön zusammen kleben damit die
schupfnudeln eben auch nicht
auseinanderfallen beim kochen
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach eine
menge dieses tages und dann formt er
einen langen etwa 2 cm dicken strang und
immer so ein bisschen mehl außen herum
damit einfach nicht klebt und dann
schneidet ihr stücke ab ich mache jetzt
einfach fünf zentimeter lang
daher ist die back matte echt auch ideal
ablesen kann
theoretisch könnte sich so direkt ins
wasser schmeißen aber schupfnudeln die
werden ebenso geformt wenn ihr möchtet
wenn ich dann lass das einfach so das
ist ein bisschen praktischer
mist der diese form der hat mich total
am markt schmecken und das hat mich an
meine kindheit war meine schwester die
asche ja ich sage extra einnahmen
sie hatte nämlich immer als kind zu mir
gesagt dass schupfnudeln aus markt
schmecken gemacht werden und dann habe
ich die nie gegessen und dann bekam ich
immer ärger von mama weil ich der teller
nicht aufgegessen hat und die ihm eine
faust gelacht
genauso wie spaghetti aus regenwürmern
gemacht werden
ja irgendwann habe ich gelernt okay das
stimmt gar nicht
aber es hat mich geärgert aber ich liebe
sie war anders
ich komme mir macht es nicht erwarten so
die kleinen geschwister die veräppelt
werden
ja aber ich war nicht so ich habe dann
zahl ich nicht veräppelt mein kleiner
bruder
okay vielleicht ein paar mal war naja
ich habe zumindest nicht behauptet ist
will ich gar nicht wissen was bei murat
alles ab gegen daheim mit zeitung
ich könnte die shop modeln übrigens auch
direkt auf der arbeitsfläche rollen das
geht finde ich sogar ein bisschen
einfacher weil man einfach die
handfläche komplett ausnutzen kann und
ihr könnt sie so wirklich auch sehr gut
vorbereiten und einfrieren nach dem
kochen
ich gebe es jetzt hier in salzwasser
wirklich reichlich salz auch dazu geben
ich finde es gibt nichts schlimmeres als
ungesalzene nudeln und schupfnudeln und
die die er kauft die sind schon
vorgekocht deswegen muss man die nur
noch anbraten und dem ist im prinzip
vorkochen und danach kann ich sehr
anbraten und das wasser jetzt hier nicht
sprudelnd kochen lassen sondern nur
sieben lassen
das geht es natürlich mehrere portionen
alle auf einmal kann jetzt nicht kochen
und dann dauerte ungefähr fünf bis sechs
minuten bis sie oben schwimmen
[Musik]
und das ging relativ schnell also die
habe ich mal sechs minuten gebraucht
sondern teilweise nur drei bis vier
minuten
und ich gebe es jetzt hier einfach im
blick und kann immer mal schwenken dann
kleben sie nicht wenn sie kleben das
auch nicht schlimm denn einem einfach
ein bisschen vom kochwasser und schritte
zu drüber und fertig und wenn ihr sie
einfrieren wollt dann macht das am
besten so dann habt ihr hier ein blech
dann nämlich meist dieses album
vielleicht weil es schon ein kleines und
wirklich in jedes gefragt hast mit
backpapier oder back folie legt sie so
nebeneinander dass sie wirklich nicht
aneinander liegen
friert sie ein und wenn sie dann
komplett gefroren sind dann können sie
ja nicht mehr kleben und dann kommen sie
zum beispiel ihren beutel und werden
dann eben schön eingepackt so mache ich
da sitzen wir mit der aktion aber wie
gesagt heute immer noch einige und ich
werde jetzt hier ganz kurz stehen lassen
die wäre jetzt einfach ganz normal
weiter verwendet wie schupfnudeln aus
der tüte
das heißt ihr könnt sie in butterschmalz
anbraten oder in butter und eine
hackfleisch pfanne dazu machen oder das
ganze vegetarisch gestalten mit
sauerkraut oder süß mit apfelmus oder
mit nutella so wie ihr möchtet
ich mache jetzt noch apfelmus dazu und
dafür habe ich jetzt hier folgende
zutaten
ich habe hier ein kilo äpfel etwas
vanille extrakt eine zitrone und wasser
und bei den äpfeln dann nehmt ihr
einfach äpfel die säuerlich sind und die
eben gut weich werden beim kochen
ich habe jetzt hier die sorte red prince
und ich lasse jetzt auch die schale dran
ich nämlich kein gehäuse raus und
schneidet einfach grob in stücke
das wasser kann hier schon mal in den
topf das brauche ich zum weich kochen
ihr könnt gerne wenn ihr möchtet zucker
zufügen aber ich bevorzuge absolut muss
ohne zucker
[Musik]
wir kommen jetzt direkt der zitronensaft
dazu damit die äpfel nicht braun werden
aber ich freue mich schon darauf wenn
wir bald mit dem elmira äpfel und
apfelmus kochen können damit nämlich
schon rosa weil nämlich der apfel innen
auch roth ist beziehungsweise und hier
könnt ihr gerne nach belieben noch
gewürze dazugeben wie zb oder nelken
je nachdem wie ihr das apfelmus eben bei
mir kommt jetzt bisschen vanille mit
rein und dann darf das apfelmus auf dem
herd kochen ich höre es ab und zu mal
durch mit deckel natürlich bist einfach
die äpfel weich sind jetzt einen schub
modeln einfach in butter oder
butterschmalz ein paar minuten
angebraten und dann verliert
die äpfel sind jetzt auch bereit die
sind schön reich und jetzt können dass
entweder zerdrücken oder hierdurch das
fleißige lieschen streichen und dann
haben wir gleich leckeres apfelmus
aber hier schon mal die erste portion
die bekommt jetzt hier die sanierer
ich habe sie mehr als probieren guck mal
ich hab sogar rosa apfelmus weil die
apfel schale so schön rot war ob der
mann selbst gemachter schupfnudeln ich
glaube die lg steht da jetzt auch drauf
wer jetzt geschafft ja super kampf
probier mal erlag oma rosa apfelmus mit
schupfnudeln magna probieren am daumen
hochgekriegt hab ich gebe euch eine
portion euch allen zum essen jetzt sogar
noch der papa papa auch noch probieren
vielleicht und besitzt ein spaß der
jungs hat gesagt mit nutella schmecken
die folge das problem jetzt nicht mehr
essen mit up in moskau warum habe ich
das gesagt was gesagt also kampusch ich
sag mal papa problem maxus sauerkraut er
warm oder kalt
also ich mag es eigentlich total gerne
kalt weil dann esse ich die heißen
schupfnudeln zu kalt um sauerkraut dann
kannst du auch warm machen
oktober ab ob jemand die schupfnudeln
oder wie murat sagt die schnüdel ist im
shop rot-gelben ja ich habe kurz gedacht
wir haben wieso macht man die selber
wenn die gekauften außer gut schmecken
aber doch nicht so gut
ja das kann ich machen heute ging es nur
um die schupfnudeln ich kann dir gleich
noch so mag vielleicht kann ich mal
angeschossen oder fleisch sauerkraut
zwiebeln jetzt was man auch einmal das
waren ja auch nicht das gespenst drei
mach xtreme pro jahr kommt schmeckt wird
normalerweise ein gemacht in die
schuften
es ist so wie wir könnt ihr auch
plastische reinmachen es passt immer
richtig lecker so können dass wir wie
gesagt einfrieren und habe dann immer
schupfnudeln auf vorrat
aber ich glaube ich gerade jetzt alle
noch fertig an denn wer ist jetzt alle
das alles ja könnte ich das machen
könnte ja mal schreiben wozu ihr
schupfnudeln am liebsten ist das eure
lieblings beilage ist und schreibt
einfach hier drunter
wie gesagt nutella probiere ich auch
noch aus das war ja stippich nicht sogar
das herz aber keine probleme mit
apfelmus sich auch selbst gemacht dass
gerade die schmale absolut
das ist schon was sich heute abend er
heute abend sei jetzt 15 uhr
ich habe nichts gegessen heute ganztag
von mit apfelmus
aber ich finde du musst du halt wirklich
anbrach draußen sauerkraut apfelmus züge
passt auch noch probiert gerne mal aus
und schreibt es dann in die kommentare
also viel spaß beim nachkochen und bis
zum nächsten mal
das ist wie gemacht war der richtige
kommt echt erstaunt fragen
[Musik]